with smartphones everywhere in every
pocket is it possible to escape selfies
everybody gets roped in it turns out
what does it mean for the rest of us the
president does it Pope Francis does it
well now some researchers are calling
this a disease selfi Titus a few people
report being helplessly addicted to
taking photos of themselves so they snap
hundreds of selfies every single day and
are simply unable to stop is there more
disgusting illnesses in the world
probably not no Daly is the
psychotherapy Stan she joins us tonight
no I mean I yeah I think it degrades
science a little bit to call this an
illness when it's really just
self-involvement of a kind that we're
familiar with but it's reached a greater
magnitude you know you know I know that
that's the gut reaction and I can see
why you would say that but I think that
there's a big difference between
thinking that someone is narcissistic
and they post selfies all the time
because they're suffering from some
element of narcissism an actual
addiction and so when you have what's
cited in this study was a bunch of young
women who are constantly taking selfies
of each other you have to understand
that these devices are super addictive
and I don't necessarily think and it
hasn't been proven that it comes from a
place of necessary necessarily from a
narcissistic place really taking if you
find your own face the most interesting
image in the world
that's not self involvement it seems
like it to me
I know I know but actually think about
it Tucker wouldn't you think that if
that's how you're spending your time and
it's impairing your daily function that
it's actually coming from a place of
really maybe perhaps low self-esteem and
so we're flooded all the time these
devices you have to understand Instagram
and Facebook all these social media
platforms are built to be really
addictive and you can't talk to any
marketing or PR agency that doesn't say
if you're trying to build a brand or a
business that you shouldn't post
pictures of yourself so that's the
message that we're sending constantly
you also have to realize that the
greatest population on Instagram for
example are young women between the ages
of 18 and 25 and what they look at the
most is makeup in fashion
we're attracted to people's faces that's
a big difference that's kind of a little
bit of a different conversation than
necessarily talking about young women or
people who are super addicted to taking
selfies unfortunately selfies make money
if you look at Instagram at all you'll
see that there's tons of people making a
lot of money by posting videos of
themselves for example putting on makeup
or doing or doing you know different
kinds of exercises and showing people
ask you a quick question
so the feminist line on this which is
dumb and wrong as usual but dumber and
wrong on this that in most says men are
the cause of women's low self-esteem
young women especially but it sounds
like these tech companies are really
adding to the sum total of unhappiness
for young women and no one ever calls
them out on that why is that well I the
first part of your comment I'm not
necessarily sure I agree with because I
don't think all feminists believe that
it's just men who are causing women to
have low self-esteem we don't want to
come on TV say that okay well I'm a
FEMINIST and I don't say that but here's
the thing it's it's um it's really
important to recognize that these
devices and I agree with you that
Facebook and Instagram need to have sort
of a bigger ethical responsibility to
create platforms that don't necessarily
push people always having to post their
face on the platforms and be super
addictive I agree right and those images
are owned by the company in the end well
thank you it's interesting conversation
thanks Tucker